y'all hear Justin Bieber smokes weed Oh
[Music]
what is going on YouTube now I have been
blasted with a lot of useless [ __ ] in my
life in fact some of the most ridiculous
[ __ ] out there that's got some of the
biggest responses for no damn reason but
did you hear that's right
hold your beer Justin Bieber smoke it we
know another innocent little girl Falls
thinking the drugs drug addicts but
apparently that's not the big problem
the problem is people are cutting
themselves because Justin Bieber smokes
weed parenting on Twitter people I
hashtag hashtag I'm coming for Bieber in
order to stop him from smoking weed that
is the dumbest [ __ ] thing I've ever
heard of my life I'm trying to figure
out the logic behind this [ __ ] how does
the freaking damage upon yourself or
someone you don't know Batman for
smoking weed hmm [ __ ] you don't know
him and if anything he knew we'd a lot
longer than you you could be hanging up
a [ __ ] clips and that'd be a
back we next to you guess who we gonna
say [ __ ] you uh plummet to your death
while he seems to a song as long as you
love me can I get that window did I
mention already you don't know him he is
nacho friend [ __ ] do you think what are
you saying he's singing a song to you
all I need is a booty energy for someone
amazing why you even think that you have
a personal connection with someone that
you have never met bet if that [ __ ] was
my deal with any idea how much I would
abuse that power because that mean it
came baby selling props been married for
seven years now in my mind call me crazy
[ __ ] you need help get ask you
something if you appeal to cut yourself
why don't you wait to leave there's like
a real drug like cocaine or meth because
if we equals cutting yourself what are
you
we'll shoot happen top you have one up
your game it's Justin Bieber does camera
hashtag scoop the spoon up my ass for
Bieber why is it that people only go to
extremes for the most useless [ __ ] this
is what you called the biggest
overreaction of the century next to this
video you got fever fever [ __ ] go to
school or get a job talking about you
got a disease you don't want to hear
that [ __ ] I'll [ __ ] backhand in the
left eye yeah I can't believe that
little sexually ambiguous bug is so
important to you that you could hurt
yourself
what if I smoke weed I bet none of y'all
give a [ __ ] David smoking hash tag ain't
nobody give a [ __ ] [ __ ] please
what would have been the smart move
instead of cutting yourself you should
have cut his ass up Beavis smoking
hashtag cut Bieber's dick I'll send him
about a million tweets of those that
should've get him to quit weed like that
my bears don't even know who Justin feel
is you know what they think is they
think he's a [ __ ] beaver because they
kept announced Ibiza dad did y'all hear
about Justin Bieber she's my mom Bieber
what you going to the Jew is pronounced
Sudan not you dance or what I said
feel good right all right yeah money in
my pocket I care
yep yeah huh Deniz once a year left he
not use that I should be really not too
late no yeah yeah I'm happy somebody
quit smoking
see this sounds like a laugh it's not
smoke some someone quits me